was machen die ganz ohne spaß wenn ich
noch weiter als ich kurze video was geht
ihr weg völlig verarmt war nicht nur
einer ist ein klares papier retten
irgendwann mal dieses tote enten gemacht
hat war alleine
der grund für dieses video wir hatten
einfach alle riesig auf diese betten
kennedy wackelt jetzt gerade
donnerstagabend ziemlich spät und dann
wird einfach ein tag wo ist ein video
das hat mir gut gepasst und wir brauchen
jetzt einen kleinen wir hätten hier 28
stück 104.000 nicht sofort
mein fahrrad 13.000 ok macht kommen zum
thema ab und jetzt bin ich fertig wurde
[Musik]
das ist kein leichter
man hat immer sein durchschnittsgehalt
[Musik]
typischen ahadi schalte runde warten um
beide beine
meinst du wählen möchte direkt von ihrem
einen abschnitt mit dem kürzel ich denke
gleich
[Musik]
ich habe gott ohne wirklich hat die
weniger man nach unten erweitern wir das
bitte etwas mehr nachfragen alter
[Musik]
abnehme jung was macht
im telefonspeicher ich will mein tennis
gewann einen golden globe bekommen
vielleicht an und dann kriegst du
gemacht hast eingespart wenn ich noch
weiter sich köppel und startet nur als
organ steigern fügte bush war die turbo
ich wollte ein türchen eindeutig würde
sagt ich habe
mehr abwarten weg dass wir glauben nein
werde ich mir auch er und war hätte
irgendwie mutet auch mit notwendigen
schub motiv wollte die jeweilige
gegenüber umgebung kleiner vorteil
djokovic hat einen trackball diesem fall
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe grund mag ihn nicht gefallen
hätte die rotter haben gedacht ich hätte
etwas um die toilette oder in dorstfeld
reiche abgedrückt
die pflanzen sollten in eine stiftung
von ägypten endete patina vorgestellt
hat und wenn das finde ich schon und
jedem eine übels auf köstliche knacken
und wenn er nur ich hab ein paar
rechnung aber nicht in bar keine stücke
richtig eklig wird sondern irgendwann
später auf jeden fall die haben das
ganze jetzt gerade kontrolliert und es
waren nicht zu sehen war
ich vor mir schon angefangen haben hat
er angefangen einfach den ganzen
auszutauschen gegen welche die man
schneller essen kann und hat dann
einfach mehr von wettermann von zehn
stück dahin wird alle 30 oder so ob ich
gewonnen und ich danke jedem zwei
stellen geben aber da ist mit mir sagen
sie einfach jeder eine unfertige nicht
machen
[Musik]
die leute gucken
mit dem video ich habe natürlich
erhalten auch wenn an sich kein
eindeutig sagen der heute kurzfristig
schreibt hat das video ist meine haare
noch nach und meine erste frage an juli
ohne spaß für die anzeige dem das herz
auch am anfang da die chicken wings mir
gegeben hat und euch wieso sagen denn
ich die kriegten stelle und
beschwerlicher was los das habe ich gar
nicht mehr statt meine seite beide 2004
ist in hand durch mich zu und fragen
mich macht es gar keinen sinn und ich
möchte das jetzt erstmal auch hier sagen
keine ahnung ob das wieder als gefallen
und jetzt viel spaß mit dem ende hier
und bestellt euch was auf dem bike shop
für höhe
ich hoffe dass ich vielleicht nicht auf
jeden fall die kanäle von daher juli und
er hat einfach der union wenn ich ihn
vorher hatten bis zwei spitze sofort
danke und weniger am sonntag wieder 3